now the Department of Homeland Security
has just released a shocking new info on
China's kovat cover-up Senator Lindsey
Graham is here on that also ordinary
citizens are making their voices heard
amid these continuing shutdowns we're
gonna speak to one tonight and Raymond
Arroyo is here with the latest
developments on the Biden's sexual
assault allegations and why some might
want a former first lady to crash the
party but first my thoughts on America
and shutdown day 49 now we have been
told throughout this pandemic that we
need to listen to the experts on
everything from the locality of the
corona virus to what the proper response
to it should be but time and again the
experts have been wrong on January 22nd
the w-h-o praised China's
[Music]
previously you know from previous
actions you see the you see I
appreciated that well Ted Rose in the
whe show a complete and utter joke okay
China was neither transparent nor
serious in preventing the spread to
other countries as we've been
documenting but then six weeks later our
politicians began making claims that
were untethered to reality like on
ventilators all the projections say you
could have an apex needing 140,000 beds
and about 40,000 ventilators we're
following the data and the science and
that's what the data and the science
says of course the data and the science
were wrong in reality in New York used
about 25% of that total and that was
good news on the severity of the
outbreak nationwide we heard things like
this we are your future where we are
today you will be in three weeks or four
weeks false in fact the only state that
came close to New York was New Jersey
the rest of the country didn't come
close to New York's hospitalization or
Cova death numbers well then we were
told the shutdowns had to be extended
because social distancing was the only
way to fight the virus
I'm just asking him to try really really
hard for these next 28 days because they
will make a tremendous difference just
keep it up because this is going to get
us out of it this is a best and only
great public health tool but the former
head of the FDA now in formal White
House coronavirus advisor Scott Gottlieb
spilled the beans on Sunday while
mitigation didn't fail I think it's fair
to say that it didn't work as well as we
expected we expected that we would start
seeing more significant declines in new
cases and deaths around the nation at
this point and we're just not seeing
that well although intuitively I think
it probably seemed like social
distancing would be necessary there was
no real scientific basis for belief
that since it never been studied and
it's one infectious disease doctor told
me last week trying to stop this virus
with social distancing is like trying to
drive a nail through jello viruses
spread that's what they do they often
weaken as they go and if it's like SARS
we hope it is it'll eventually burn out
as SARS did an observational study by a
researcher at Woods Hole Oceanographic
Institution not yet peer-reviewed
examined whether stay at home orders
actually prevented deaths in Western
Europe comparing the trajectory of the
epidemic before and after the lockdown
we find no evidence of any discontinuity
in the growth rate doubling time and
reproduction number trends we provide
estimates of the death toll in the
absence of any lockdown policies and
show that these strategies might not
have saved any life in Western Europe
well if true I say if that would be
stunning and the author does echo the
sentiments of Nobel laureate Michael
Leavitt of Stanford University what's
your view of the lockdown policy that so
many European countries and states in
America have introduced I think it is a
huge mistake I think that everybody
panicked they were fed incorrect numbers
by epidemiologists there's no doubt in
my mind when we come to look back on
this the damage done by lockdown will
exceed any saving or glides by a huge
factor that's what I heard today at my
own doctor's office because no one's
there and as the public wants answers
while some of the experts are hailing
the results of new expensive drug
therapies with middling evidence of
success but warning us away from cheap
generic drugs that have already saved
lives both here and abroad and the FDA I
hate to say it but they got this one
wrong big time well of course every drug
has potential side effects and in
prescription drug interactions there's
more than ample evidence at
hydroxychloroquine saves lives speeds up
recovery time and cuts down on
hospitalizations
it's also one of the safer drugs out
there just by virtue of the fact that
it's been around for what 65 years and
as I've mentioned before Frances
esteemed epidemiologist professor Didier
rahu and his team of colleagues release
the results of hydroxychloroquine in a
thousand 61 kovat patients good clinical
outcome and very logical cure were
obtained in 973 patients within ten days
no cardiac toxicity it showed 91%
effectiveness in eight deaths so why is
the FDA not so much as noted the work of
this premier epidemiologist in all of
Europe and by the way Chinese
researchers release their own
retrospective study on Friday and they
found equally impressive results using
hydroxychloroquine in patients who were
seriously ill 568 patients critically
ill with kovat all received basic
therapy but additionally 48 of them
received hydroxychloroquine for 7 to 10
days 200 milligrams twice per day
hydroxychloroquine treatment is
significantly associated with decreased
mortality in critically ill patients
with Kovan 19 through attenuation of
inflammatory cytokine storm
therefore hydroxychloroquine should be
prescribed for treatment of critically
ill Koba 19 patients to save lives
ok well we can say consider the source
this is from China and it's not yet
peer-reviewed but in a pandemic as
Professor Rowe has said with lives on
the line and still no established
therapy or vaccine not everything can be
peer-reviewed experts are not always
right none of us are it can't be no
one's infallible but in times like these
sometimes we have to take yes for an
answer
now finally about all of those bad
models the experts were all over the
place and projecting the virus's
lethality we're going to bring down the
number of infections so we don't have to
point to million deaths or 1.6 million
deaths I wouldn't be surprised if we saw
a hundred thousand deaths it's more like
the 60,000 then 100 to 200,000
okay if you're not confused yet now
they're saying that a hundred and twenty
hundred thirty four thousand could die
bike Ovid by August of what that's
double what they were saying a few weeks
ago so why is this happening well the
expert at IH NV a University of
Washington did a lot of this modeling he
explained it this way we're seeing many
states reporting on presumptive deaths
that were missed in the official death
data and now they're going back finding
deaths that were in nursing homes elder
care facilities and reporting you know
large numbers of those deaths on a given
day that just means that more deaths
occurred that means the trajectory of
the epidemic is also bigger ah
retrospectively adding death to the
covin count no issues there I'm sure no
issues with accuracy except that we had
one of the worst influenza pneumonia
seasons in decades in the United States
not reported very often is it so we're
still trying to get a final count on
those flu and pneumonia deaths from the
CDC by the way haven't gotten them yet
very very strange well the experts
strike again
and those are my thoughts at the end of
day 49 America in shut down